ja mein thema ist die ampel riskiert die
sicherheit deutschlands und europas mit
blick auf beispielsweise den
koalitionsvertrag wo ganz wichtige
themen
relativ unscharf formuliert werden
beispielsweise der frage wir halten
jetzt seine eigentlich mit der nato und
dem nachwuchs ziel der 2 prozent
investitionsquote oder wir erhalten
jetzt zum beispiel einen ganz wichtigen
punkt mit der nuklearen teilhabe das
gleiche konnte man sehen bei dem
antrittsbesuch des bundeskanzlers in
brüssel bei der nato auch hier der
dezente hinweis ja man ist schon bereit
weiter in die bundes wären die deutschen
streitkräfte zu investieren aber nur im
rahmen was halt der haushalt so hergeben
da kann ich nur sagen
sicherheitspolitik nach kassenlage das
ist nicht so schlecht oder auch
natürlich jetzt die
regierungserklärung des bundeskanzlers
gestern gestern
75 minuten über soziale wohltaten über
gesellschaftliche umbau dann kam erst
europa und die sicherheitspolitik dran
und in diesen in diesem zeitraum der
dann folgte war genau einsatz zur
bundeswehr und das finde ich insgesamt
zu wenig und das macht nicht nur mir
sorge sondern das macht auch tatsächlich
unseren nachbarn sorge unseren
bündnispartnern und das natürlich nicht
ganz zu unrecht denn wir werden
tatsächlich bedroht wir werden ganz
konkret von der russischen föderation
bedroht das ist nicht nur die ukraine
sondern das erleben wir durch
cyber-angriffe durch entsprechende
propaganda die auch hier stattfindet
durch verletzungen von lufträumen der
nato und und und es gibt viele viele
beispiele und deswegen hoffe ich dass
die ampel tatsächlich hier im wenn sie
so richtig angelaufen ist auch ein
klares statement gibt für die nato für
die bündnisse und für ein sicheres
europa es ist ein ganz wichtiger punkt
der in der tat im koalitionsvertrag
völlig unterbelichtet ist ich kann mir
das erklären aus der kenntnis der
psychologie der drei parteien in keiner
der drei parteien ist es wirklich
beliebt sich mit militär zu beschäftigen
die fdp hatte ja auch eine große
kampagne gegen zwangsdienst also zur
abschaffung der wehrpflicht
damals und ganz aktuell sind wir
natürlich in einer situation wo man sich
einfach klarmachen muss
verteidigungspolitik
nicht immer im einsätzen zu von waffen
aber das drohen und das auffordern zu
konsequenzen hat nur dann einen sinn
wenn der andere auch konsequenzen
fürchten muss und das ist in der tat
seit jahren ein problem da ist die
letzte bundesregierung auch nicht ganz
schuldlos daran der aufwuchs bei den
verteidigungsmittel ist nicht ganz so
schnell gegangen wie das eigentlich
wünschenswert gewesen wäre und ich
erinnere mich an eine episode als wir
mit der kanzlerin bei einem treffen mit
der arabischen liga waren und frau
merkel dann gesagt hat ja
man müsse aber multilateral
zusammenarbeiten und hat aufgefordert
den krieg im jemen zu beenden an saudi
arabien gerichteten haben der das auto
show prinz gesagt er könnte diese reden
nicht mehr hören deutschland ist das
land was immer moralische appelle übrig
hat deutschland kann keine waffen
liefern weil man einen kriegshelden
nicht liefert deutschland behindere
seine partner in der nato bei der
lieferung weil man keine schrauben und
andere teile liefern darf an nato
partner die diese waffen fertig bauen in
deutschland kann nicht mal eine fregatte
schicken die sich vor die küste legt und
sagt wir drohen hört auf also waffen
sind nicht immer nur dazu da um ein
gesetz zu werden sondern um eine
wirksame drohkulisse aufzubauen damit es
nicht erst zum krieg kommt und vom
libanon sehen wir dass wo in deutschland
seit jahren mit einer fregatte liegt und
soweit immerhin deutlich macht haltet
frieden dann ist alles prima also
wichtiger punkt ich weiß noch nicht so
richtig ob die neue
verteidigungsministerin das wirklich
einlösen wird man sie haben gesagt
waffen sind nicht nur zum anschauen da
gewissermaßen aber sie müssen natürlich
auch funktionieren wenn wir haben
natürlich schon unter der vorgängerin
von vollamtlich frau kramp karrenbauer
der unions familie angehören schon das
problem dass die ausstattung der
bundeswehr nicht gerade die weltweit
bestmögliche gewesen ist also wir haben
glaube ich schon seit jahren ein
allgemeines desinteresse bei führenden
politiker aber vermutlich auch in der
gesamten gesellschaft an einer wirklich
validen wehrfähigen interessenspolitik
und ich glaube das ist das problem das
wir uns in der außenpolitik fast
abgewöhnt haben interessen zu
formulieren die außenminister maas hat
es glaube ich auch nur sehr selten
gemacht vielleicht macht vorburg jetzt
besser ist wenn ihr sehr zu wünschen
aber wir haben schon seit jahren
eigentlich auf dem posten des
verteidigungsministers und auch des
außenministers nicht so das klassische
spitzenpersonal dass man hätte wenn es
wirklich von diesen vitalen wäre für den
ist faktisch ist 600 wer wäre so ein
spitzenmann oder ein dutzend ja das ist
jetzt die 100000 euro frage also ich
hätte mir einen anderen steht zur
verfügung zur verfügung hat
beim nächsten mal ja ich hätte noch
einen anderen vorschlag wir haben mit
mehr demokratie der organisation der ich
angehöre für den bundestag im auftrag
der bürgerrat deutschlands rolle in der
welt im januar durchgeführt und da war
genau die frage welche rolle soll
deutschland eigentlich zukünftig in der
welt einnehmen und 32 empfehlungen
wurden tatsächlich von 160 bundesweit
ausgelosten menschen erarbeitet und eine
empfehlung war zum beispiel
dass das zwei prozent ziel in der nato
auf jeden fall eingehalten werden so
eine klare empfehlung allerdings auch
mit humanitären und zivilen mitteln
inbegriffen aber immerhin einen
deutliches dafür unter ebenso hat sich
auch der bürgerrat dafür ausgesprochen
in einer empfehlung die die
militärausgaben entsprechend auch
anzuheben wenn dann gesagt das notwendig
ist also ein panzer nicht funktionieren
oder überhaupt einsetzen nicht möglich
sind dann ist einfach not an mann da
frag ich mich natürlich diese empfehlung
wurde dem bundestag übergeben alle
fraktionen haben sie bekommen haben die
verantwortlichen politiker das auch
ernst genommen das ist eine klare
empfehlungen da können sie sich
orientieren also ich kann nur sagen
erstens habe ich an diesem prozess auch
gerne teilgenommen und das war in der
tat ganz spannend und ja also wir haben
sie haben es richtig beschrieben er
kessler wir haben da schon in den in den
letzten jahren zu wenig getan wir haben
aber auch muss man ganz ehrlich sagen
mit unserem unserem koalitionspartner
abgetrotzt das ist trotzdem einen
gewaltigen aufwuchs tatsächlich gab wir
haben also eine steigerung von 50
prozent zum vergleichszeitpunkt 2008
sicher stolz jetzt gut ja ja das ist
auch interessant weil er war immer
derjenige der sozusagen das gebremst hat
mit seiner fraktion und sagt jetzt
schaut mal haben wir ja eigentlich
gemacht aber gut das es gehört zum
politischen spiel dazu aber in der tat
also diese dieser mangel wurde schon
früher gesehen und das wir konnten uns
da nicht durchsetzen aber ich fürchte
halt dass sie das jetzt noch eklatanter
tatsächlich wird und
wir brauchen hier dringend in vielen
bereichen weil es ja nicht nur so dass
sozusagen die bedrohungen in den dingen
die wir so kennen zu nehmen sondern es
kommen ja noch ganz andere faktoren dazu
die auch extrem teuer sind
beispielsweise selber wer beispielsweise
auch das ganze thema weltall also wenn
wir darüber reden dass wir
digitaler werden müssen dann muss man
sagen
rückgrat der digitalisierung ist
tatsächlich die raumfahrt und ist das ei
und wenn wir das nicht beherrschen und
dort die infrastruktur schützen können
russlands gezeigt denen sie mal kurz
einen satelliten verdammt haben und auf
einmal tausende von teilchen
tatsächlich auch unsere mission
gefährden dann ist das schon auch ein
klarer eine klare bedrohung die uns auch
dort gezeigten gerät nicht immer fair
sein wir haben ein segelschulschiff
renoviert das ist ihr zu lange und aber
nicht jetzt hier sehen waren des
angesetzten preises aber wir können
jetzt wieder über die weltmeere segeln
da muss man einfach auch fair bleiben
ich meine wir reden immer von der
wehrhaften demokratie demokratie fördern
selbst jetzt die situation das ist immer
nur nach innen gerichtet natürlich muss
eine demokratie innen gegen ihre feinde
wehrhaft zeigen auch wer kraft zeigen
aber die innere demokratie wird auch
zerstört wenn sie nach außen auch nicht
wer fähig ist und insofern glaube ich
wir können nicht immer sagen nach innen
ist es ganz wichtig demokratie zu
schützen aber nach außen meldung spielen
wir gar nicht mehr mit beim aus
politischen kräfte spieler